foreign
[Music]
our top story inside China's closed and
controversial region my thousands of
uyghurs have been moved from
re-education camps
really an incredible eeriness to this
place and it just is completely
abandoned signs of what used to be are
everywhere though
we speak to relatives of those now
detained and see how the prison
population has massively grown also
tonight
knocking their socks off a shoeless
prime minister at a summit in Japan
insists he'll remain prime minister once
British voters have their say
thank you
the questions for Scotland's first
Minister as he can't say whether this
man who abducted a school girl while
dressed as a woman won't be detained in
a women's jail
cleaning up their act for 10 billion
pounds England's water companies and a
costly pledge
it's read every training manual we've
ever used with our team it's read every
bit of Regulation
[Music]
a game changer or job killer why AI may
already be on calls to replace thousands
of jobs
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
foreign
[Music]
good evening for years the so-called
re-education camps in China's xinjiang
Province have been a symbol of the
oppression of its Muslim uighur minority
tonight we have evidence many have now
closed but the threat is far from over
instead we've seen what appears to be a
huge increase in prison accommodation
and we've spoken to at least one
relative whose loved one has been sent
there
well since 2017 uyghurs have been
subjected to a program of intense
oppression at its height it's estimated
between 1 million and 2 million uyghur
people were imprisoned
evidence from leaked police files shows
people as young as 15 and as old as 73
were detained
back in 2021 the U.S government
determined the actions of the Chinese
government in xinjiang amounted to
genocide and crimes against humanity our
Asia correspondent helenanne Smith
visited 22 sites across xinjiang
province
on the streets of xinjiang there is
still attention and signs of what this
place has been through
heavy police regular stops
a sense they're always watching
it is now Infamous for its brutal
oppression of the Muslim uygha minority
and there are questions as to how far
that policy is ongoing
it is the camps that characterize the
Crackdown places like this
experts and survivors say it once held
uyghurs arrested on mass and subject to
so-called re-education but we found it
Dusty deserted
it's really an incredible eeriness to
this place and it just is completely
abandoned
signs of what used to be are everywhere
though
around the front one building cordoned
off from the rest appeared to be acting
as temporary housing
and some of the buildings over there are
they are they empty
I don't know this man says there were
people here when I first arrived
that ominous
looking Kemp was built where we had
beautiful dreams as a children it's
unbearable it's Unthinkable this place
is haunting for mechan he knows his
brother Emma Tian was held here it might
be closed but his brother is not free
after two years here without charge a
police officer told him what happened
next according to the police officer he
said that my brother
had a sensitive book which was banned by
the government uh impromptu kind of
court was held court hearing was held in
the camp and he was sentenced to 14
years
China says everyone held for
re-education has now graduated
over 90 percent of the re-education
camps we visited were visibly no longer
being used for this purpose most now
appear to be schools the reality may be
far more complex
in fact while arrests spiked in 2017 at
the height of the Crackdown they remain
higher than they were before it started
prosecutions jumped up too and there was
a huge increase in average sentences
meaning most of those people will still
be locked up
if not in the camps then where
what we're now doing is taking a trip
further outside the city center because
what we've heard is that the camps that
are further out are more likely to be
still used for that purpose and that's
also where some of the larger prisons
are that we think in some cases might
have been expanded some it seems they
did not want us to see
we found all the roads to one large
cluster of facilities were blocked
those we did reach were fearsome eight
in total all clearly operational and
satellite shows some have recently
expanded in 2018 towards the end of the
Crackdown this site hadn't even been
started watchtowers added just recently
and here too a prison right next to a
re-education camp extended while the
camp pot had its walls and watchtowers
removed
the initial wave of arrests might have
passed but the fear they've wrought has
not this woman is one of the very rare
few to have escaped within the last two
years even from a place of safety she is
visibly terrified it's all lies most
people are still inside although it
looks as if everything's normal people
who were deemed a bit problematic had
taken always and no one knows where
they've been taken to they don't say
anything about what happened to them
when they were inside but it's obvious
that they've experienced extreme Horror
in response to our story China's foreign
Ministry said allegations of the camps
are sheer lies and the vocational
schools helped people break away from
terrorist and extremist ideas everyone
has now graduated
the message is that everything is normal
here now the Crackdown may be less
visible for many it still feels very
real Helena Smith Sky News in xinjiang
a correspondent inside
now the leaders of the world's biggest
advanced economies are gathering in
Japan tonight with a further Crackdown
on Russia's economy on the agenda an EU
official said the country's lucrative
Diamond trade will be discussed Rishi
sunak will be part of the global talks
but is also spoken about his domestic
future more on that in a moment but
first from Hiroshima our political
editor Beth Rigby reports a warning
there is some flash photography
Rishi sunak and his wife akshata Marti
arrive in in Tokyo hoping to cement his
growing status
on the international stage the pm at a
naval base this morning greeted with
Pomp and a parade which rose
to the occasion a show of military might
protecting peace in this region their
priority to counter an increasingly
unpredictable China
the UK signing and defense agreement
with Japan with the aim of strengthening
security economic and technological ties
we're increasing our engagement in the
region to work with allies like
Australia like Japan to ensure that the
Pacific region does remain free and open
we don't want to see any change to the
status quo by force or coercion this
region is going to be increasingly
important to our economic prospects at
home if you look at where Global growth
is going to come from Over the coming
decades the indo-pacific region is going
to be increasingly important important
because
celebrating Japanese investment for jobs
in the UK I'm delighted to announce new
investment commitments worth nearly 18
billion pounds this is a huge vote of
confidence in the UK economy and with
that the Whistle Stop tour continued on
to Hiroshima as the G7 leaders assembled
the mood one of optimism determination
and unity but the geopolitical Outlook
Bleak war in Ukraine a rogue Russia and
Rising aggression from China these
allies have plenty of problems and the
task here in Hiroshima this weekend is
to not just show a united front but a
preparedness for action too
tonight Mr sunac meeting his Japanese
counterpart sporting socks featuring PM
kashida's favorite baseball team a small
gesture but with big intent this a
relationship a region of growing
importance and where much is at stake
and Beth is in Hiroshima for us tonight
Beth Global Security and the war in
Ukraine on the prime minister's agenda
there but also his political future at
home
yes that's right Julian I'm here in
hirosha it's very wet morning here as
you can see uh this is the day that the
G7 conference really kicks off but the
Prime Minister as you said been asked to
about matters back home and on the plane
over we asked him I asked him about
whether or not he was confident he would
still be prime minister after the next
general election in light of those local
election results and I got an emphatic
yes he said I'm working hard to deliver
for the British people he said he was
confident he could he said he knows
things are tough right now and he said I
think I've made good progress in the six
months I've been in the job I'm just
going to keep at it the Prime Minister
also emphatically ruled out any
Coalition deals saying that he wasn't
interested in talking about deals he
wouldn't do a deal with the dup it might
be a hypothetical question anyway given
that it's not far from Clear whether the
dep would want to deal with the
conservatives over after what's happened
with base brexit trading Arrangements
but that was the kind of domestic line
if you like coming out as we came over
to Japan now today in Hiroshima uh big
International talks really kick off and
high on the agenda of course is the war
in Ukraine and I talked in my piece
about actions not just words when it
comes to Ukraine look out to day for
sanctions growing sanctions it's
expected that the UK could announce
further trade in sanctions might there
be action on Banning Russian diamonds
into the UK Market is the prime minister
going to announce a new raft of
sanctions and will other G7 leaders
follow it looks like there could be a
coordinated effort here to increase
sanctions and send a strong message to
Moscow here from Hiroshima okay Beth
thank you very much uh Beth Rigby
bearing in Washington night
now the fate of the transgender rapist
Isla Brighton was one of the factors
blamed for the fall of Nicholas sturgeon
now her successor has Scotland's first
Minister has faced questions over
another similar case Hamza Yusuf
couldn't say whether a man who is
transitioning to be a woman might be
held in a women's prison after he
admitted abducting and sexually
assaulting a schoolgirl our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillies reports
here is the face of a pedophile whose
crimes have traumatized a schoolgirl for
Life 53 year old butcher Andrew Miller
and here is the same person identifying
as Amy George seen in February luring a
youngster into his car while dressed as
a woman thinking she was safe she
accepted a lift home before the Predator
locked the child in his bedroom for
hours subjecting her to repeated sex
attacks today Miller admitted it all the
court hearing the child only escaped and
phone 999 after her abuser fell asleep
the judge here described these crimes as
abhorrent and every parent's worst
nightmare sentencing will come in August
but there has been a major row here in
Scotland about where to retain trans
prisoners that led to a policy change
meaning their birth gender overrides
everything Miller will therefore be
detained in a male prison the Scandal
earlier this year surrounded trans
double rapist Isle of Bryson being
temporarily detained in a woman's prison
first Minister canis guy use questions
Scotland's first minister in light of
this fresh case oh first of all can I
say that this is a gut wrenching case
heartbreaking I cannot think of the
trauma the victim and the the family of
the victim in fact the community
are going through I can confirm of
course that Andrew Miller is being held
in a male prison but I can't see which
one and I can't go into the details and
will he continue to stay in a male
prison well again look this is a live
case the sentencing is still to happen
so I can't comment any further but of
course he is being held in the mail
estate but can you rule out that he will
not be moved to a women's prison I
cannot come in a life case you should
know that political deja vu in a
polarizing issue as Andrew Miller Amy
George prepare for a long period behind
bars Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
the rise of artificial intelligence is
like a freight train heading towards the
workforce the boss of one Energy company
has told Sky News workers at BT may know
exactly how he feels after the telecoms
giant announced today that around 10 000
jobs will be replaced by Advanced AI in
the next seven years our business
correspondent Paul Kelso reports
I would definitely say that's something
that we should do when you pick up the
phone to accompany this is what you hope
you'll get a human to help sure I can
set that up for you over the phone but
send an email to octopus energy and the
answer might now start with artificial
intelligence it's answering 44 of
customer emails just seven weeks after
it was introduced so whatever email
we've ever sent to a customer it's uh
read every training manual we've ever
used with our team it's read every bit
of Regulation I mean it's read every bit
of the Arcane back end of energy
it kind of just knows it all right the
boss says AI won't cost jobs here but it
is a threat to workers in The Wider
economy around the world governments are
quite quickly beginning to think about
what they have to do here uh but we
haven't got time to wait and see because
uh you know look if a freight train is
coming at you you don't wait till you
feel it hit before moving out the way
that'll be too late
generative AI is changing the workplace
fast this London Law Firm has a bespoke
AI tool being used by three and a half
thousand lawyers in 43 countries just
three months after it was launched on an
individual basis it's a boring
productivity game really it's an hour or
two week but when you multiply that by
three and a half thousand that is a big
deal for a business well before this
existed would that been a realistic
Target if you'd been asked to find more
three and a half thousand dollars it's
impossible it was impossible to find
these productivity gains through a
single deployment of a system a year ago
we have done this job losses are
inevitable BT says it will replace 10
000 workers with Advanced AI by 2030 and
they won't be the only ones government
has no plans to legislate but unions say
rapid adoption of AI threatens workers
rights we say that at the very moment at
which regulation is most needed when the
Technologies are developing so rapidly
and the implications are so significant
instead of regulating the government is
putting forward flimsy and vague
proposals that don't have any statutory
footing
artificial intelligence could trigger
Industrial Revolution for White Collar
work with the prospect of huge
productivity gains coming with warnings
that millions of jobs might cease to
exist
you can't know where that balance
between promise and pain will settle AI
will create new roles even as it
consumes old jobs but the speed of
change is fast turning science fiction
into a fact of working life Paul Kelso
Sky News
two teenagers are beginning life
sentences tonight over the murder of a
Schoolboy Kyrie McLean was just 15 when
he was stabbed after leaving school in
Huddersfield one of his fellow pupils
told Sky News everyone wanted to carry a
knife for protection there shingi marike
reports
for Charlie McLean the death of her son
Kyrie meant she lost the most important
thing in her world today the two
teenagers who murdered him were given
life sentences
in a statement read out on her behalf
outside of court she simply asked why
I now ask myself what has this achieved
what has my son died for
nobody has won in this situation I have
lost a child and other parents have lost
two children who have been who committed
this offense and are now in prison
this violence has to stop
fifteen-year-old Jacob pusey was
sentenced to a minimum of 17 years in
prison his cousin 17 year old Giovanni
Harriet sentenced to a minimum of 18
years
the court heard how the pair Lane wait
for Kyrie outside his school in black
clothes and balaclavas for a pre-planned
attack that saw a 30 centimeter blade
plunged into his chest
outside the gates the ties Trinkets and
tributes are reminded of how the victim
was still a student
the killing of a 15 year old in broad
daylight as he walked home from school
shocked his friends family and The Wider
Community here in Huddersfield it's also
raised questions about an increase in
knife crime across West Yorkshire
AJ who goes to the same school says it's
violence that is now commonplace
what's the curry knife for protection
around here like I know a lot of people
do
but again like you know you just gotta
constantly look over your shoulder even
though I'm not involved in your any any
of that obviously I come here as well
so you just you don't feel safe no more
at this Boxing Club they've made it
their mission to address the issue it's
one close to home Kyrie trained here
briefly before he died I've lost four
children now I've dealt with the last
four years to knife crime
um Kyrie came here as part of the school
initiative we all put we put on and it
breaks me out
for a mother this loss has left the hole
that will never be filled
it's always those lives that have been
devastated they bring the cruelty of
life crime into Focus shinki marike Sky
News leads Crown Court
brmt Royal Union has announced another
strike for Friday the 2nd of June the
walkout will affect 14 train companies
and involve twenty thousand station
staff train managers and Catering staff
feed it meanwhile the National Education
union says its teachers will hold
another round of strikes in July if
their long-running dispute overpay
hasn't been resolved by mid-june the Neu
is rebalancing its members to seek a
mandate for another six months of
industrial action
the treasury has revealed that the late
Queen's funeral and lying in state last
year cost more than 160 million pounds
the home office which provided policing
and security shouldered the biggest
share of nearly at nearly 74 million
pounds
the party Goods business founded by the
parents of the Princess of Wales has
been sold after it failed to avoid
collapsing into Administration the sale
of party pieces Holdings was done using
what's known as a pre-pack
Administration that means it had
appointed insolvency practitioners
before being sold without some of its
liabilities
the port of whitstable in Kent is famous
for its oysters but one seller we spoke
to today said he's importing them from
Jersey because of concerns over sewage
in the water there the trade is just one
of the victims of inadequate sewage
systems something the industry promised
to spend 10 billion pounds improving
today customers though will pay for it
as Ashner huronag reports
it's long been our waterways big dirty
secret tons of filthy water often sewage
pumped into rivers and seas whitstable
in Kent is no exception
it's why Jean and her friends have been
avoiding it
this is their first dip in six months I
bring my grandchildren down here in the
summer and I know I'm not sure whether
they should be allowed in the water or
not because you never quite know do you
and it's it's a worry with young kids
[Applause]
now there's a 10 billion pound pledge to
clean up our sewers and this admission
it should have been solved years ago I'm
here on behalf of the water industry to
say sorry sorry for the spills of
untreated sewage that have gone into our
rivers and onto our beaches and to say
today we get it we've listened we've
heard we understand the public upstairs
anger that has been about this issue and
we have a plan to put it right
a plan that will see shareholders make
an initial investment but then
eventually will be passed on to
customers since 2010 water companies
have paid over 20 billion pounds to
their shareholders according to the
University of Greenwich and last year
there were more than 389
000 spills across Britain which
campaigners say we shouldn't have to pay
for it's just so enormously frustrating
when you see that they're taking a
billion pounds plus a year in dividends
and the CEOs are getting paid 25 million
pounds a year and then we're being told
well if you want this issue fixed you're
gonna have to pay again but we've
already paid for it one well this is the
purification Center where all their
oysters are actually should be purified
in the Oyster capital of the UK business
owners like Graham depend on the water
quality but he stopped relying on the
ones on his doorstep instead spending
1200 pounds a week to get them from
elsewhere I've gone to jerseys because I
can guarantee that if I sell this to a
restaurant I'm not gonna have any
complex they will sell this Restaurant
They're not going to have any issues
whereas whereas if I use the local water
I do not know
[Music]
there's the price of keeping his
reputation intact
foreign companies wanting to fix theirs
the cost will be far steeper Ashner Sky
News in whitstable
finally last night on Sky News at 10 we
covered the claims by the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex over near catastrophic
car chase by Paparazzi in New York today
what actually happened is not much
clearer the view from America's media
though is as our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone reports a warning this story
contains flash photography throughout
from NBC News this is today predictably
the sussex's Manhattan drama was the
morning Show's headline news the
American obsession with the Royals
ostracized or not playing out on their
streets the tabloids here have their
views of course it's less a couple
hounded much more a couple of hypocrites
they've left New York now and left the
dust to settle on the varying versions
of the events of Tuesday night
it was at about 10 pm when Harry Megan
and her mother left the Ziegfeld
Ballroom in Manhattan with private
security they headed towards where they
were staying on the Upper East Side they
were then driven across 57th streets up
and down Franklin D Roosevelt East River
Drive and other streets for about an
hour and 15 minutes Sky News understands
the couple then entered the 19th
Precinct Police Station the first of
three times that night in an attempt to
lose the photographers
at 11 PM they left the police station in
a yellow taxi driving South on Park
Avenue before returning on the third
occasion they stayed for about 15
minutes and were then transferred into
an SUV which headed to their friend's
house
all of a sudden paparazzi's came out of
nowhere and started flashing uh taking
pictures and uh you know and they didn't
stop until the security got out and said
move move
the takeaway from all this of course is
that as ever there are starkly different
accounts of what happened how near
catastrophic this really was it's
certainly true that New York's traffic
even at night gives ample opportunity
for photographers to do what Harry
resents what he fears so much but the
Eternal tension is of a couple who want
a private life in the public eye on
their terms Prince Harry has faced these
challenges since he was a young child
he's been in the public eye and will
continue to be in the public eye they
have to find the right balance doing the
things that are important to them in a
public role with the Privacy that they
crave
deeply intrusive or a situation they
helped to create
either way the context of course is the
tragedy of Harry's past markstone Sky
News in New York
well that was Guy News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front page
of the Guardian the headline reads fresh
sanctions against Russia as PM seeks to
Rally support for care tonight we're
going to be joined by The Daily Express
columnist and broadcaster Carol Malone
and the Belfast Telegraph Congress
Alison Morris to stay with us for more
[Music]
thank you